who at this point should be 100 renting
and who should be 100 buying at this
point in their life High earners
perfectly fine to rent if if taking time
away from your job will cost you more
money than you could make in real estate
don't get into real estate so like what
you guys are trying to build at
valuetainment there's times where it's
like a rocket ship you cannot be
distracted by other things when you're
like I gotta go down this path yeah
imagine if I'm flying to Madrid and I'm
interviewing Andrew Tate with PVD and
they're like uh the toilet's not working
I got no time for that make a decision
what your tenant wants this or that
right and you don't have people that can
handle that for you on the same time I'd
say the person in the blue collar
position the plumber the I'm a software
engineer at this company and I make 75
000 a year and I'm just gonna get steady
raises they need to be investing in real
estate because they're not going to
build significant wealth work in that
same job for 25 years where they don't
have the controller power to earn more
income you're the W-2 person you don't
have agency over how things go you need
real estate when you've got more agency
and more skills you can pick and choose
your battles with where you're going to
put that money this comes back down to
the offense defense analogy so yeah I I
I actually agree with that but I think
it's very important that you clarify not
you know not everything works for
everyone what is that different strokes
for different folks because if you
Google uh and is that whatever that
you've never heard Different Strokes no
we all know what you talk about Willis
um but if you Google should I buy should
I rent there's a million different
articles that are basically saying if
you rent you're throwing way money it's
a waste of money how could you be so
stupid so foolish and then it's uh
buying is overrated you forgot about
taxes insurance and maintenance and it's
not all it's cracked up to be but the
answer is you got to pick the path
that's best for you most of those
articles are terrible they're not
they're not giving you the full picture
it's not what it is it's somewhere when
people say with the 2016 whatever the
Warriors when they had their best year
beat the 92 Bulls like it you can't
answer that question they played the
game differently the rules were
different you built your team
differently it's a fun thing to talk
about There's no practical answers
that's a dumb question to be asking
should I rent and do this or should I
buy or do that there's too many
variables to make that yeah clear right
so if you're going to be investing in
real estate the better question is how
to do it what what am I getting into how
do I prepare for it and if you don't
want to invest in real estate then ask a
different question what could I invest
in and if you're buying stocks or you're
just going the traditional route of a
portfolio of stocks and bonds you got a
lot more more energy to put in the words
excelling at what you do and so and so
put all your energy there fully agree
you play to win the game exactly now
walk us through what we got I know we
need to wrap up in the next couple
minutes so we've got one question we've
got here
um and then I think there's one more
question um it's what's your experience
wholesaling California
so wholesaling is a term we use if
Adam's got a property he doesn't want it
anymore it's worth five hundred thousand
dollars he either doesn't know that or
doesn't care he's like listen man if you
buy this thing from you it's yours for
300 Grand and I go put it in contract so
I have the right to buy your property
then I go to you and I say hey do you
want to buy a house worth 500 grand for
400 Grand so I'm tacking on a wholesale
fee of a hundred thousand dollars and
when I'm selling I'm not selling the
house I'm selling you the right to buy
the house at the terms that I already
negotiated and I saw the question pop up
earlier the problem is in Orange County
he said I'm having a very difficult time
finding anyone that will sell their
house for what it's worth so I can't
make that wholesale fee and that's
because you're in Orange County everyone
knows what their house is worth yeah
wholesaling tends to work better in
areas where people are ignorant they
don't know what their house is worth or
they just aren't good with money like I
just got a problem get rid of this thing
I don't really care what this house is I
just need you to take it off my hands
everyone in Orange county is financially
literate you're not it's a it's a rough
area to try to be wholesaling got it so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauce test click right here
[Music]